joël barre des bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat aux élections législatives où
vous présenter dans la circonscription 3
celle de fort de france sur la liste la
martinique avant tout alors pourquoi
vous présentez-vous à ces élections
législatives qu'est ce qui vous motive
j'ai envie de vous répondre pourquoi pas
qu'est ce qui me motive
c'est pas le fait de vouloir un
carriériste bien sûr c'est le manque
d'eau proximité
le manque encore une fois je me répète
le manque de politiciens le box imiter
donc vous ne pouvez pas avoir une
politique de proximité
donc des amis
sont penchés sur le sujet et ils m'ont
dit tiens pourquoi pas avec ses
affinités que nous avons et manet en
sont bien sûr avec d'autres que d'autres
amis et on se dit pourquoi pas alors
quelles seraient vos priorités deux ou
trois si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée
nationale pour le thé l'ensemble du
territoire martinique vous savez nous à
la martinique avant tout on n'aime pas
vendre du rêve aux gens donc j'attends
j'entends bercy le par la d autres
candidats
qu'il faut
revoir la précarité la centif il ce
n'est pas tous nous on a comme objectif
d anc avait un petit peu le transport
viser la culture le tourisme
et vous savez c'est pas la peine d
numérique 14 mai de projet et une
affaire que deux nous on est lui mais à
trois où elle a fait au moins alors
désenclaver les transports effectivement
c'est une grosse problématique alors
qu'elles sont un petit peu vos quelle
est votre analyse et les solutions les
pistes de solutions que vous et votre
équipe envisagez vous avez
votre émission
très bien mais en cinq minutes on ne
boit pas non mais là tu fais tout ça
mais bon un petit fruit vous savez on a
on a pas mal de projets concernant le
transport
c'est à dire qu'il faut nous mêmes on
pense qu'il faut à faire vivre le trash
mans un exemple tout bête pour faire
démarrer les entreprises sous forme
france d'accord parce que il est
inadmissible exemple que je donne que
des entreprises avec la ville de fort de
france soit villemant à partir de 17h et
comme ils disent très bien la
problématique vient du classement s'il
n'y a pas de transport ya pas qu il n'y
a pas de clients y avait de monde donc
pas transitivité il faut commencer à
développer le transport pour vous les
transports c'est un levier du
développement économique absolument pas
pour moi seulement beau tout le monde il
est inévitable de constater que
je vous donne un exemple tout bête si
vous avez une vanne une amie qui
voudraient voir un spectacle à l'atrium
à 20 heures qui n'a pas de véhicule elle
est condamnée à faire du stop a demandé
à un ami un parent pour s'y rendre et
quand le spectacle fini à 22h
qu'est ce qu'elle fait qu'est ce qu'elle
fait et l'immobiliser donc il faut
développer ce genre de transport nous on
a une petite solution on ne dira pas
qu'on a la solution mais on pourra
éventuellement amener une idée mais
ajoute une idée simplement d'ouvrir je
serai quoi
si vous voulez oui non mais monnet la
pause on est là vont dévoiler si vous
voulez on a le système ce que nous on
appelle le noctambus si vous voulez
c'est un métro mais
à l'hexagone c'est un métro souterrain
nous on le veut le mettre sur terrain et
vous allez voir comment
on ne sera pas des moindres noctambus
pas ce qui sera aussi nocturne ah oui
parce que vous vous imaginez 17 heures
il y avait deux bus des jours fériés bon
il en train de développer martini
transport mais dans l'espace sud ça va
mais nous ce qu'on veut c'est avoir une
un classement permanent permanent afin
que les martiniquais ne crée pas pour
simplement aller voir un spectacle on va
du cultuel alors joël bardet et qu'avez
vous à dire aux électeurs pour les
convaincre de voter pour vous c'est très
simple jeu je n'ai pas cherché à
convaincre les électeurs parce que pour
moi joël barre des îles sont déjà
convaincus ils sont déjà convaincus et
ils l'ont montré ils sont convaincus
qu'il faut changer ce système politique
qu'il faut changer certains politiciens
pour ne pas dire tous on est gentil
maintenant ils l'ont démontré je encore
une fois je me répète je n'ai pas
convaincre c'est à eux de me convaincre
ça et de me convaincre de désister sur
ce problème parce que pendant des
premières élections avant le premier
tour des élections présidentielles les
martiniquais ont montré à nos zélus à
nos élus qui on demandait à voter mâcon
qui s'était compte qu'ils n'étaient pas
contre mâcon qu'ils étaient contre
l'idée que des élus doc d
nous donne des des consignes comme des
dictateurs
au deuxième tour il envoie montrer
qu'ils sont contre les idées de nos élus
nous vivons d'échangés merci joël barre
des témoins